J it's good to see you you too thank you
why this book why a book about the Peace
Prize I thought it was a good idea I
hope it is it's a very interesting
subject I find I mean quite apart from
my book and its qualities it's just a
plain interesting subject and I think an
author can only mess it up it it gives
you the Peace Prize gives you an
overview of the 20th century because the
prize like the other Nobel prizes begins
in 1901
so you march through the first war and
the depression second war cold war-era
Israeli conflict environmentalism war on
terror Obama almost everything this
prize has its finger in mini pots then
you have this vast cast of characters
all these laureates and other people who
surround the prize and they're all
interesting least I found I am some
people said to me as I was writing the
book and the book was lengthening well
concentrate on the interesting ones and
skip over the less interesting ones but
they're all interesting or at least I
found and then that the book rather the
subject makes you confront some of the
biggest questions concerning war and
peace and freedom and tyranny and it
makes you decide what you believe or
what you consider nearest true so I
found it a really rewarding exercise to
study the Nobel Peace Prize it's a it's
a juicy subject regardless of what I've
done with it it's a juicy subject well
yeah I was struck in reading the book
that in some ways that when you when you
add up all of them the the Peace Prize
is like a Rorschach test and and it's
usually controversial in any given year
there's usually somebody who's very
unhappy about it
but over time almost anybody can find
something to like or hate about it and
we say in golf every shot pleases
someone and every Nobel Peace Prize
election pleases someone and displeases
obviously was there any particular
impetus you know Barack Obama winning
and people saying what's this about or
drift or anything any moment or
something clicked that you said
I'd like to look more deeply at this
well I decided to write a history of the
Peace Prize before Obama won naturally
this idea was first suggested to me in
2002 after the prize was announced for
Jimmy Carter and I thought it was a good
idea and I put it on the back burner
until 2009 or so and then I returned to
it so it is true I have to be reminded
that the incumbent president is a Nobel
Peace Laureate sometimes I forget I want
to talk about some of the recent events
and winners but I think we should start
by going back can you tell us a little
bit about what you learned about Alfred
Nobel and what the original vision for
the Peace Prize was and and how it came
to be I I loved getting to know Alfred
Nobel I don't know if you found the same
mat I I really enjoyed reading about his
life and sketching his life in this book
he jumps out as one of those sort of
quintessential 19th century figures with
a lot of different interests and
activities and a seemingly bottomless
energy and enthusiasm what a talent what
a talent he he was a brilliant chemical
engineer and chemist probably a genius
decent right tough to gauge he was a
brilliant entrepreneur and manager he
presided over an empire of something
like 90 factories and facilities victor
hugo called him Europe's wealthiest
vagabond he traveled all the time
managing these things still inventing
and corresponding he must have been one
of the most prolific correspondents of
his age he wrote thousands of letters a
year and in five or six or seven tongues
all idiomatically he wrote in the tongue
of the recipient he was a brilliant guy
and I enjoyed reading many of his
letters complicated man
sometimes a sunny idealist an optimist
and sometimes a dark dark cynic and
about 355 patents
his most famous invention is dynamite
but we're told by people who no I'm not
no but we're told by people who know
that dynamite is not his most
significant invention that was something
else but nine mites the most famous and
there's this myth always has been that
he established his prize for peace out
of guilt over his invention of dynamite
and I think I say in my book that it's
hard to know exactly what's in a man's
head and heart but this seems not to be
true it seems that he was quite proud of
his achievements in the area of
explosives they built what today we call
infrastructure canals tunnels railroads
the Central Pacific Railroad in this
country in fact he also was a great
believer as you recall from the book in
the power of deterrence and the ability
of terrible weapons to deter war perhaps
even eliminate war he was an over
believer in deterrence and if he had
seen just a little that 20th century
especially the first war I I think his
views would have been different as many
people's views were different he dies in
I think 1896 and he writes his will one
of the most famous wills ever written in
1895 and he wills
five prizes want me to shut up for a
while I will I realize I've been
monologuing no no no go ahead because I
am interested figure and and and your
book wrestles a lot with his vision for
the Peace Prize yes and and how well the
vision has served your risen sir but
that's one of the real dominant themes
of the book I think well I find that the
American would think this that that the
will is kind of like the US Constitution
and there are people who interpret it
strictly and a strict constructionist
and there are people who are really
loose about it it's a living document
it's a vessel that we fill with our own
thoughts and with the times and so on so
the will is often been ignored and now
and then followed but he establishes the
five prizes and in his order they are
physics
I was letter she started with chemistry
his specialty but he starts with Physics
Chemistry Physiology or medicine as he
puts it literature
and peace and what's missing there is
economics it's not a real Nobel Prize
it's an add-on from the late 1960s it
was established by the central bank of
Sweden and its formal name is I think
something like the central bank of
Sweden prize and economic science in
memory of Alfred Nobel and they don't
mind if you and I call it a Nobel Prize
they're happy not to correct us I think
but in formally it's not a Nobel Prize
it's something else but any case Alfred
Nobel established has five prizes and
the last for peace and he wants the
prize to be given principally for those
who further the cause of fraternity
between nations that's his signal phrase
and the will regarding the Peace Prize
fraternity between nations also he wants
all of his prizes to be awarded for work
done during the preceding year right
this was a surprise to me I always
thought the Nobel Prizes were kind of
cumulative awards or Lifetime
Achievement Awards or golden handshakes
at the end of a an illustrious career
well I think in that I think if I didn't
do the math but I think that probably no
more than ten or a dozen of the winners
as you write about them probably
actually fulfill the specific criteria
that Nobel laid out I think you're right
one could easily do a count and I did
not but I think that's true well it
pretty quickly there's one other element
I think you should talk about which is
there's a kind of a Norwegian yeah yes
at the heart of the Peace Prize and the
time when the Peace Prize was was was
created so you can you talk about that a
little bit there's a there is a very
special quality from Norway that I think
informs the Peace Prize and all the
Nobel is really like yes well he has
Alfred Nobel has his five prizes and it
gives four of them to sweden - swedish
bodies to administer nobel himself was
swedish he did most was growing up in
st. petersburg very cosmopolitan fellow
but he was swedish and at bottom a
patriot very much the universal man but
also a swedish patriot and he gives for
the prizes to sweden and the fifth one
to Norway
he asked the Norwegian Parliament
to elect a committee of five to
administer this Peace Prize and he
doesn't say in his will that the five
committee members must be Norwegian and
there was a debate about this in Norway
in the very beginning in 1900 1901 1902
should we have an all Norwegian panel or
an international panel arguments on
either side but since day one it has
been an all Norwegian panel and I say
some of my Norwegian friends don't like
it when I say this very much but I think
one could say that the Norwegian people
elect the legislature the legislature
elects the Nobel Committee
therefore the Nobel Peace Prize is a
reflection of the Norwegian people and
their political culture and how do you
describe that culture how do you think
that it's social democratic mainly isn't
there um there are very strongly social
democratic collectivist country in which
the phrases Social Solidarity is very
important they're not um Reds they're
not commies they may be a little pink
certainly by American standards there is
one Reaganite or Thatcherite party in
Norway now call the Progress Party
there's kind of attention to that
emerges between Norway is a small
country yeah it was allied with as you
said Sweden for a long time in Union was
weaned until 1905 so what also comes
across as a funny kind of there's a
funny cosmopolitan aspect to Norway as a
small country and at the same time a
kind of parochialism as a northern
slightly remote country it was a fishing
village and for oil yeah I sure won't be
seen in Norway well yeah believe it or
not yeah you know this some people may
snicker at this but Sweden at the end of
the 19th century at the beginning of the
20th was a bit of a power not a great
power but substantial and significant
and Norway was not and so the belief was
that nor would be disinterested and pure
above it all without real geopolitical
interests objective and it's an arbiter
of mankind and like other little Nations
at ups absolutely adores international
organisations and places great emphasis
on the UN as it did to the League of
Nations emphasis on the League of
Nations and also before the League of
Nations something called the
inter-parliamentary Union and and
organizations that crop up in its
history like the Red Cross particularly
which is on what I think one three or
four no bells like three yeah yeah there
are certain organizations that it comes
back to as well as particularly in
wartime and at certain moments though
they seem to have a soft spot for
doesn't Doctors Without Borders I think
one in 1999 surely part of its
psychological this isn't very um there's
another impolite thing I'll say
international organizations are away for
a very little and powerless country to
be somebody also I think the Norwegians
are very keen to check American power
and they in others regard international
organizations as checks on American
poverty the Germany do you think it's
American power but because of something
about America or do you think it's any
dominant world power and it just it's
been America's moment for quite some
time do you think it's probably the
latter probably the latter yes certainly
since certainly since World War two it's
been the u.s. now I had the impression
when I read the book that you went into
it thinking some things about the Nobel
Peace Prize as I suppose we all do we
all have opinions and we all like to
debate it and that as you reported some
of what you you some of what you've
thought maybe turn out to be true and
then some of it some of what you learn
may have challenged some of your
conceptions so can you talk a little bit
about what surprised you about the
process and what you learned in the
Peace Prize
and and and and where where you had a
particular conception that also turned
out to be to be true mm-hmm many of the
laureates I didn't know many the
laureates were new to me and I enjoyed
getting to know them I really enjoyed
getting to know an early anti-apartheid
leader named Albert John Lou Tully yes
he was a Zulu chief and president the
ANC and a dedicated Christian and a
great man a strong man and a meek man I
very much enjoyed getting to know him
his kind he was a practitioner of
non-violence an advocate of non-violence
and his kind went away with the banning
of the ANC and with its going
underground and with the rise of people
like Tambo and Mandela I very much
enjoyed getting to know Lou Tully and
many others including a German pacifist
named Linda Ludvig Linda or quitte qu i
d de some of these pacifists I must say
were quite sensible and even stirring
and brave and in my time in our time the
word pacifist has been a bit of a slur I
mean if you call someone a pacifist he
may well object you know who you calling
a pacifist or anything but certainly
before World War two and very much
before World War one if you had said to
someone hey you're a pacifist he might
well have said to you well of course I
am what are you a militarist pacifism
was posed against militarism enjoyed
getting another pacifists they were
wrong in my judgment but they weren't
monolithic they were different and had
different views and took different
actions I found peace a very slippery
concept I have a section in their little
essay on peace and an abused
concept and an elusive concept what is
peace after all we we know it's not the
mere absence of war everyone says that
but it's not war either is war the worst
thing in the world probably not but it's
a nasty horrible murderous thing to be
avoided if you can there comes a time to
stand and fight these are all tricky
questions and I guess what I found was
that the Nobel Peace Prizes altogether
our mixed bag a few were the prizes I
think that are that are clearly good or
clearly bad I think most of the time the
Nobel Committee has had a case or case
lit a bit of a case even Arafat a lot of
people said to me as I was I was writing
the book and I tell them when I was
doing writing a history the Nobel Peace
Prize and they'd kind of wrinkled their
face and say didn't the Arafat when that
and for them that's the end of the story
what more do you need to know and I mice
there was a committee member who
resigned after that award to horrified
and I would have been with him I think
but it's well to remember that
Arafat did not win the prize alone in
1994 he won it in concert with two
Israeli states when the two top
statesmen the prime minister of beam and
the foreign minister Paris and the two
of them were happy to appear in Oslo
with Arafat to accept this prize or at
least willing to do so and the foreign
minister went out of his way to say in
his Nobel lecture that our thoughts
share in the prize was quote fitting
unquote
so the RF at the RFI example is an
interesting one in the context of your
book because what I felt throughout was
that you were taking seriously the
winners reading their speeches listening
to their words trying to see their views
and then along the way
you mentioned the pacifists you were
pretty open-minded about little
discoveries about people even if you
disagreed with them and and one of the
things that I think the strongest thing
that emerges in the book is that what
you just alluded to this rustling with
peace what does peace mean that's been
there almost at the beginning despite
what Alfred Nobel I'll put it as well in
terms of the specifics
and and what does jump out is the sort
of interesting ongoing discussion and
debate and even the Nobel Committee
there were years were they come out and
talk about a candidate and you think as
a reader boy they got it wrong and the
next year they the same people give a
stirring speech in a dress yes that's
right that's right and in my view some
of the laureates turn lousy after they
win very bad kind of activism but they
weren't awarded for that they wouldn't
they didn't win the no-take linus
pauling a genius of a chemist terrible
bull she certainly a fellow traveler a
great supporter of a Soviet Union
apologist for the Soviet Union
he he won not just the Nobel Peace Prize
but the Lenin Peace Prize in the Soviet
government which began life as the
Stalin Peace Prize and he said that the
prize from the Soviets meant more to him
than the prize from the Norwegians but
he won the peace we first won the
chemistry prize which was clearly
deserved he won the Peace Prize for his
advocacy of a nuclear test ban which
after all was signed by President
Kennedy and other cold warriors so what
do you do with that was that prize
ignominiously the pollens political life
was but was that prize maybe not so much
I want to talk about some of the Nobel
winners just before I do I want to come
back to something that you started to
speak about which was the notion of
peace and the wrestling with that how do
you see the concept in terms of you you
have an essay where you talk about peace
and it is a slippery concept and it's
the prizes moved well beyond the
boundaries that Alfred Nobel laid down
did you come out of the experience of
this thinking that that kind of fluidity
and flexibility was good or do you think
that there's a certain different
guideline or way to think about peace
that is more useful I mean how do you
see what is peace for from from your
view
there's political peace or national
peace or world peace there's individual
peace or spiritual peace Margaret
Thatcher I'd like to talk about peace
with freedom and justice the Soviets
were very big on the word peace
they were the peace-loving nations they
in their block the West call themselves
the freedom-loving Nations the Soviets
named their space station Mir which
means peace as well as World Soviets
were always banging on about peace and
they did favor a certain kind of peace
the peace that comes with absolute
submission to the party and state that's
a kind of peace stability dictatorial
stability ah not our kind of peace we
think more about peace with freedom and
Bill Buckley said that sometimes a
little bit embarrassing but sometimes
the biggest concepts can be boiled down
to embarrassing bumper sticker language
great better dead than red better red
than dead the New Hampshire license
plate says live free or die okay but how
many are willing to follow that I mean
how are we all Bravehearts when you
stand and fight and when you reach an
accommodation and these these were all
tough questions I am I'm very aware if
people talk about peace we had that
phrase from Jeremiah peace peace of R is
no peace and you may remember that
stinging criticism that Tony Blair made
he was going off to do some diplomacy in
the arab-israeli conflict and he said to
george w bush before he left now if I
win the Nobel Peace Prize you'll know I
failed
and I don't even I'm not that hard on
the Norwegian Nobel Committee well
really you kind of suspect Tony Blair
wouldn't mind if you want them to Nobel
Peace Prize - oh I don't think it turned
it down so so peace you know if someone
like me and I'm Reagan conservative and
something like me can think you know
listen to there's a piece Knicks and
what what MacArthur called piece cracks
Reagan quotes us in a letter McArthur
call them piece cracks that piece is
just a joke a farce a snare in the
delusion a crock a real piece isn't
we're not very far in New York from
Grant's Tomb
you know they joke about Grant's Tomb
who's Barron Grant's Tomb it's a
Riverside Park over here if I had my
bearings and I walked by it now and then
and it says let there be peace war
killed over 600,000 people Americans and
population wasn't that large at the time
just think of it carnage and I think war
is necessary and just and right every
now and then but there's nothing like
true peace I quote in my book I love
this line from or well it comes from one
of his novels coming up for air before
the war
meaning the Boer War when there was
peace it was summer all the year round
if you can get peace you've really
gotten something but the question is
what is factually used to say yeah yeah
you guys talk about peace but whose
peace Poland's Bulgaria's the Peace of
the grave
these are tough questions well let's
talk about some of the winners and that
should give us a chance to reflect more
on some of them I pulled out some of the
ones that struck me who do you like well
one of the woman you enjoyed getting to
know if I may may ask well let me well
one of the ones I wanted to ask you
about who I thought really stood out
who's probably all but for God today was
Karl von etske oh I think 1935 during I
believe if I'm not mistaken a decade in
which a couple of novels were skipped be
during the Depression and we should
mention that you used to be much more
common than has become in recent years
to not award a Peace Prize and there are
many decades in which one two even three
years I think in one or two cases were
skipped you are right now it comes every
year like Christmas for somebody anyway
yeah but he he stood out as a fairly
compelling figure and and one of the
bravest men of his time as far as I'm
concerned yeah to talk about him a
little bit and what you look did you
know about him at all before before I
started the research on the book only
vaguely only vaguely he was a German
journalist and pacifist he he was jailed
even before the rise of the Nazis for
criticizing German rearmament for German
violations of the Versailles Treaty but
he was free and walking around in 1933
when the Nazis took power or were
elected to power and they arrest him
right after the Reichstag fire and they
put him into a to concentration camps
prisons and concentration camps they
torture him they demand that he renounce
his principles he refuses they torture
him almost to death there was a campaign
especially by a German Nobel laureates
in all the fields to get him the Peace
Prize
they wanted him to have the Peace Prize
for a few reasons first I thought it
might save his life
second they wanted to honor thee this
was the phrase of the time the other
Germany the better Germany and they they
did give him the Peace Prize in the year
1936 for 1935 and I think Goebbels went
to OCS ki and told him to refuse it and
OCS ki told him to stuff it and of
course they wouldn't let him out to go
to Oslo he died in a sanitarium
they gave him better quarters but he
died in 1938 I think and he was a gutsy
guy and it was a gutsy decision of the
Nobel Committee because Germany was
threatening the Norwegian government
folks yes he got this prize would be
very bad for the for for Norway and
Norway had stayed neutral in the First
World War and they were hoping to stay
neutral in a second there was to be one
Sweden was very cross with in our
Regents we're doing this because it
rocked Sweden's boat too and Hitler and
his government for bad after the prize -
och ski Hillard US government for bad
Germans to accept any Nobel Prize in any
field and they created their own prize
as a substitute Nobel and for the
duration of the Reich those prizes were
in place I believe the first I think of
three times when that was done because
the the Soviets did it and I think the
Chinese have just started doing it since
2010 I believe you are right you are
dead right well yeah that's key stood
out because partly because in some
senses aside from being a brave
individual of himself this election it
belies some of what we might think about
the Nobel Peace Prize because it was a
brave pick as you say at that time in
Europe for them to name somebody like
that it's interesting because if a
couple of years later there's debate
about I think on the committee about
Neville Chamberlain who did not get it
but debate about I think he would have
been 1939 if there had been a 39 prize
which there wasn't not to invade Poland
September 1st the prize has
traditionally announced the second week
second Friday of October
the prize was kind of suspended during
the war but if there'd been a prize for
39 probably Neville Chamberlain would
have received it he was heavily
nominated so was Hitler by a Swedish
parliamentarians look if you're gonna
nominate the British signatory to the
Munich pact you might as well
nominate the German signatory they
dodged a bullet on that one they were
lucky the committee was the nomination
of Hitler was withdrawn but but
Chamberlain might very well have
received the prize if there had been one
for 39 let me go back a little further
to I think the first really
controversial pick not the history which
was Teddy Roosevelt no they're still
grousing about that and some people
they're still upset about the prized @tr
well it's actually interesting because
again he's he's it does happen in in the
prize history that somebody like TR
who's a little more militaristic I think
it's safe to say or at least pro strong
defense and his personality pops up his
piece Wow yeah and and always a little
movie
tell me about his his Nobel and and and
why it upset so many people I can quote
that New York Times who said a broad
smile surely illuminated the face of the
globe
when this prize for peace was given to
the most warlike citizen of these United
States said the New York Times oh they
were upset but he had mediated a truce
in the russo-japanese war 1905 it led to
the Portsmouth treaty signed in
September 1905 Portsmouth New Hampshire
also he was a friend of the arbitration
movement those who wanted international
disputes to be settled not by war but in
an international court in Holland he was
friendly to this cause but he was also a
very strong believer in deterrence and
in his memoirs he wrote that the best
thing he did for peace was to send the
u.s. battle fleet around the globe
that didn't sit well with some people
but his nobel lecture which he gives
after his presidency when he's on a
grand tour world tour is majestic and
true it is one of the best meditations
on peace I've ever read frankly what a
writer
yar was I I occasionally forget that
yeah he was a historian really from his
earliest days but what stands out about
that address is it he talks he wrestles
with what we were talking about what is
peace after all
and he says let it not be an excuse for
tyranny he's working he's also the first
as you said I think the first real peace
through strength figure in the nobels
history which is another been just a
heads up you know really general
Marshall in 1953 another very
interesting one which I wanted to talk
about another one and and actually one I
think the you you you say was pretty at
that time in Europe he was an extremely
popular figure yes and there wasn't much
debate about that although his speech
was an interesting speech too well he
won you and I think his great
contribution to peace was the defeat of
Nazis you didn't win for that he won for
the Marshall Plan as he was the only one
not to call it he called it by his
formal name the European recovery
program everyone else called the
Marshall Plan that's what he won for the
same day Winston Churchill was honored
in Stockholm with a Literature Prize not
the Peace Prize but Marshall gives a
most unusual Nobel lecture probably
Nobel lecture least like a Nobel lecture
he says that disarmament and
demobilization and demilitarization have
been disasters for his country and for
other democracies we were back on our
heels before World War two and we were
back on our heels again unprepared for
Korea and he said basically a much
better language in mind its soldiers
like me who have to clean up after
people like you officers like me you
have to send young men to die because we
were because we weren't properly
defended
because we were naked unto our enemies
and so that's not the kind of thing
they're used to hearing in Oslo and he
gives them the prize name was
controversial because he'd been after
all chief of staff for the army and he
gives a very very very thoughtful and to
me commonsensical speech but how did it
go over it was controversial you say but
he was also a very popular figure dude
he was beloved in Europe yeah
when I say controversial though I mean I
mean by the controversial in the what's
called in the chattering classes
controversial prize controversial choice
on the Left well among academics among
Nobel Peace Prize devotees people people
revered George Marshall who in a way fed
and reconstructed Europe he did some of
what Herbert Hoover did after the first
war Hoover was one of the men very
heavenly nominated for the Nobel Peace
Prize who never wanted 1950 I figure who
I think was quite prominent then it was
was that Ralph Bunche lunch in 1950 was
one who stood out very prominent at the
time not very well remembered today but
another very interesting figure can you
talk about him a bit yeah III remember
his being on a US postage stamp a couple
decades ago and I was glad to see that
bunch was one of the most impressive men
we've known he's born in 1903 or 1904 I
think he himself wasn't sure the black
kid born in Detroit makes his way to LA
raised by his grandmother really parents
are gone parents are dead in fact I
think after a bunch is about 13 and he
went to
a white high school Jefferson High I
think in LA he is the sports star and
the valedictorian a basketball
scholarship to UCLA again a sports star
and the valedictorian of UCLA we're
talking about a young black American in
the nineteen teens and 20s the black
women of LA raised a thousand dollars in
cash for him to put in his pockets as he
goes across the country to Harvard he's
the first black person to earn a PhD in
political science in America from any
university has a master's from Harvard
as well he has a flirtation with the
left and the hard left but he rejects
them it becomes a un diplomat
and presides over truce negotiations
between Israel the new State of Israel
and its Arab attackers in 1948 1949 and
he wins a Nobel Peace Prize in 1950 the
Nobel Committee was very keen on
honoring that new United Nations giving
it a boost and very keen on saying that
the the UN shall be the arbiter of
disputes and a bunch was the first
non-white recipient recipient to the
Nobel Peace Prize for those keeping
score yeah he jumps out from the pages
of the book a little bit and there are
several figures like this of people as
the one who was prominent in his day not
very well remembered today but worth
getting to know again and reflecting on
him a bit which i think is one of that
one of the great things at the book it
does there's a smart cookie
made mistakes for sure but a smart
cookie and an all-american you talked a
little bit about the era Fabri being
Perez award there's one that may even be
more controversial I think you know what
I mean from 1973 was controversial Nobel
Prize of any kind ever given yeah well
can you talk about that that's dr.
Kissinger and Lee doc towel over there
yeah
well in January 1973 Kissinger the
National Security Advisor and lay doctor
than North Vietnamese emissary signed
the Paris agreement this is supposed to
be a truce to the Vietnam War the North
immediately violates that explodes it
but the Norwegian Nobel Committee gives
the prize to Kissinger and ladakh toe
kids there's no Secretary of State in
the fall of 1973
Kissinger was I think a little
embarrassed to see make fries it makes
illusions then and future years two
other Nobel winner yes his own
worthiness I yes I think I think it made
relations with President Nixon a little
bit all right kiss Nixon so wanted the
Nobel Peace Prize it worked so hard for
peace with honor as he called it between
the United States and North Vietnam but
that Kissinger gets it and lay docto
refuses the prize which is a an insult
in a way a Kissinger doesn't go to
collect it and in 1975 when Saigon Falls
and the treaty is nothing he tries to
return the prize the medal the diploma
and the money and the Norwegians in Oslo
tell him essentially the Nobel Peace
Prize is not returnable you earned it
for what you did then this was not
contingent on future success you win it
when you win it for work you've already
done and Kissinger says in his memoirs
that he would he would have rather won
the Nobel Peace Prize for his so-called
shuttle diplomacy in the Middle East
that he was proud of and Elie Wiesel
Wednesday as I recall wins the Nobel
Peace Prize in 1986 he telegrams with
what we still doing telegram son I can't
remember he he telegrams he's a telegram
were fax I don't know yeah and says I
was not proud of my own prize I am proud
of yours you know the 73 was interesting
because it it created an uproar
particularly the kissinger half of it
Tom Lehrer says that satire ceased to be
possible it can absolutely no Kissinger
won the Nobel Peace Prize
I think it far more shocking that the
envoi of a totalitarian and
mass-murdering dictatorship won a Nobel
Peace Prize but the opprobrium was
attached to the American Secretary of
State the foreign minister of a liberal
democracy I regard that as a bit weird I
think what is interesting about that
prize too is in in one sense it's
defensible because it use more closely
to the actual parameters Nobel laid out
than many of the others eternity between
nations in the preceding preceding year
at a time when after years in which
Vietnam had roiled the world and world
relations and there was real hope of
relief but of course as you also go on
to point out just a few years later
after the fall of Saigon tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people are died in Vietnam it's a goes
to a different kind of a piece where
there is a unified Vietnam but it's not
a peaceful situation at all and so you
could also look at that prize and almost
everybody can see something they just
like in that prize today I was impressed
by something I heard Vernon Walters the
late general and diplomat and CIA men
say I was in college at graduate school
I think he said for 12 years in Vietnam
there was terrible he swore he said
bombs rained down on every city town
village and hamlet in South Vietnam and
no one budged
no one budged during that time they took
the coming of a peace if you will the
wrong kind of peace to send six or seven
hundred thousand out in the South China
Sea on bits of wood or tyre or anything
that might float to risk piracy and
dehydration and drowning
and it took peace to do that he said and
I remember that concentrated my mind a
bit when I heard that that let it took
peace to send those almost a million out
into the South China Sea fleeing in
terror that kind of pieces that and why
is that better than war necessarily
rottenness war is it's actually one of
the interesting things that the prize
does is it does provoke discussions and
reflections and thoughts about peace and
what we think of peace and over time in
some cases as that one did it was it
still debated and argued about I thank
you
another the 70s was a busy year for the
the prize so there's a couple of other
years I want to mention there one is the
Sakharov Prize in 75 which stunning a
noble thing a great act talk about that
all that well a leading a Soviet Russian
whatever you prefer a dissident a great
physicist to threw away his glorious
career at the top of the Russian
scientific heap to speak up for human
rights and freedom and dignity and the
Norwegian Nobel Committee gives him the
prize in 1975 Soviet Communism lasted
Soviet Communism and power was from what
1917 to 1990 and one in D Warrior and of
course there were great many heroes in
this period dissidents political
prisoners prisoners of conscience
activists of different kinds and and all
over the Communist world Soviet bloc
certainly and there are only two awards
given by the Norwegians to people the
anti-soviet cause you might say soccer
off in 1975 and luck Walesa or of a win
say in 1983 those are the only two
awards there were three anti-apartheid
awards
but the the award soccer off in the
award to a lesser of a winter or very
important and had an effect I mean it's
interesting too because the soccer off
one stands out is one of the shining
prizes and also reflects in the context
of the peace discussion a different view
of what we mean by peace because it in
the same way that Aussie atsuki does or
some of the anti-apartheid ones that you
mentioned might they are essentially not
specifically related to fraternity
between nations they're sort of within
Nations and they're actually recognizing
really victims prisoners of conscience
is a you know the term for want of a
better one simply for their moral stance
and their forcefulness and their views
which has become a popular way to be the
peace prize but it's a little bit
different I think the Nobel originally
might have perceived it yes I wonder
what he would have thought I've had to
ask myself these questions about what
the Peace Prize should be I think that
the committee should generally follow
the will but that rules out some of the
best prizes that would rule out the
prize to lack valensa for exact and he
he told me in an interview that without
the Nobel Peace Prize his solidarity
cause and Poland could never have
succeeded the way but it was there was
no wind blowing into Poland sails and
after we won the Peace Prize there was
wind in our sails well that's one of the
real benefits of a right is then they're
very aware of that when they sit down to
vote in Oslo the Peace Prize at the
right time the right person can really
impact events yes it can be a weapon in
fact I learned something from a book
that Robert Kagan wrote about Nicaragua
called a Twilight Struggle
it's about the Sandinistas and that
drama the Norwegian Nobel Committee
gives the 1987 about Peace Prize to
Oscar Arias the president of Costa Rica
and they tell him privately we're giving
you this award to use as a weapon
against Reagan because arias and Reagan
were in disagreement about Central
America and arias told Bob Kagan Reagan
responsible for my prize so this can be
an award with with power some people
think that it gave East Timor tiny East
Timor its freedom its independence has
it brought down the Burmese dictatorship
no but Ansan Suki is is well known you
could really argue that that prize
propelled her to a global presence that
she's still 21 years later as Myanmar
seems to be opening up that she's still
benefiting from there really did propel
her though she was famous before and she
has been more famous after same with the
Dalai Lama I would say who receives the
Nobel Peace Prize in 1989 what had done
for Tibet
not much practically but people know the
cause people know the Dalai Lama
personally they know the cause of Tibet
and the Nobel Peace Prize is not solely
responsible for that but it has helped
I'm sure well it's got it got under the
skin of the Chinese and stayed there I
think after that yes there are a lot of
people talk about we could talk for
hours but I want to go a little bit to
the last decade because interestingly
some of the many Bush Nobel swell right
some of the most controversial nobels in
two ways there's the political element
as you alluded and I think and you get
into this the book the the definition of
peace changes again over the last ten
years with some of the prizes I'm
thinking of Al Gore's Prize particularly
talk about the last decades worth of no
bells because you spent a lot of time on
them we can save Barack Obama tyll tyll
tyll I've never talked about the the
Bush years well when we got 2001 right
after 9/11
Ward is announced in October the prize
goes to the United Nations and its then
Secretary General Kofi Annan it's the as
you know the centennial of the Nobel
Prizes 1901 to 2001 and it was natural
for the Nobel Committee to honor the UN
but they were also saying they were
admonishing the American administration
and this new war against terror if were
to have one don't you dare go it alone
everything must go through the UN that
was a message of that Peace Prize and I
think the chairman in history do you
know that I mean that's your camera is
pretty explicit in his so-called
presentation speech that he gave at the
Prize ceremony yes and he was very
explicit the next year when the prize
goes to Jimmy Carter and when the
Chairman announces the prize to Carter
he says this prize is intended not just
as a personal award for mr. Carter but
as a kick in the leg to the American
administration and all who followed that
line and kicking the leg is an
expression that we learned it's a
Norwegian way of saying slap in the face
or poke in the eye so that was Carter
2003 Sharina body I think the Iranians
human rights lawyer 2004 one gallery
Mathai I think Kenyan environmentalist
2005 well and and and let's stop on 2004
for one second we'll get back with Al
Gore but environmentalists the first
environmentalist the Nobel goes green
that's right right right and and
controversial a little bit in the sense
of bringing environmentalism into the
concept of peace as we see a
controversial for some people anyway
that's right environmentalism was on the
rise
math I was also honored I don't believe
they had ever been a black woman and the
Nobel Chairman says this is meant to
honor the women of Africa in general as
well that math I was a very interesting
figure she launched a tree planting
movement she was a political dissident a
woman formidable woman a woman of talent
she came over the United States to study
in the same program as Barack Obama's
senior from from Kenya that's right and
there's been other quasi environmental
nobels
and what do you do with the 1970 war to
Norman Borlaug for example the great
agronomist and there's a 1949 award to
John Boyd or who is the first leader of
the FAO I have those initials right food
and agriculture organization I think the
UN yeah but but maybe 2004 was the first
explicitly green in the contemporary
sense award oh five the International
Atomic Energy Agency and it's then
director-general Mohamed ElBaradei
people wondered is this another kick in
the leg it was seems pretty clear 2006
Muhammad Yunus he's the Bangladeshi
micro banker or micro lender that was a
off-the-beaten-path Nobel Peace Prize
that was one I think President Clinton
had lobbied very very hard for him and
he had a lot of sort of institutional
support out there yes he was always
advocating the Peace Prize for Eunice
and I think the Nobel Chairman says now
you know Bill Clinton can get off our
back we've we've done it by the way
Clint this seems to be one of the few
top Democrats these days not to be a
Nobel Peace Laureate yes when I was
feeling about that they've given it to
Carter Gore and Obama Hall neither
Clinton well that's well there you go
yeah yeah trying to think of relatives
have won the Peace Prize I don't think
so you have to go back well madam Curie
is we used to call her but she went to
scientific prizes the first with her
husband yeah I'm trying to think about I
can't remember the part of the founding
ethos on who won in the 50s I think wife
of one of the earlier widow of I was
recognized are we thinking of album ear
doll one of the first day right economic
price now the renard always ever yeah
the mirror dolls I don't remember the
name that's right Al Gore once worked
under the MIR dolls in the American
dilemma project when he was a bunch was
a young scholar sorry go on to Al Gore
because that's definitely among the most
controversial well just as a little
aside or piece of trivia I the subtitle
of my book is um I think history of the
world's most famous and controversial
Prize and I think pretty clearly is the
most controversial prize but this
business of fame the most famous that
maybe a bit of a fudge because it could
be tied with or maybe a little surpassed
by the Oscar I'm not sure how you'd
measure this on a worldwide basis you
know some international some global
Gallup might be able to
but I think they're probably about tide
and one man in one year 2007 wins both
awards that was Al Gore an amazing thing
almost surely will never happen again
and I say that if you're gonna lose the
presidency in such a hard way it's some
compensation to win the world's arguably
the two most famous prizes in a single
year and he says essentially this in his
Nobel lecture that the Nobel Peace Prize
certainly has come as a kind of bomb
following that extraordinary
presidential episode in 2000 but yes the
global warming campaign was I would say
at its Apogee in 2007 I think it looked
a little less good after with
Climategate
and all of that and I think they might
have been lucky to win when they won but
when if they did in 2007 do you think in
the history of the nobels when you look
at some of these controversial ones from
the last decades and we'll talk about
President Obama in just a minute but do
you think that there's been a real shift
in how they think of the Peace Prize in
Oslo in the last decade versus the first
hundred years or are such are some of
these just sort of within the tradition
of the of the prize going back and forth
there is always there's some evolution I
think that the Norwegian Nobel Committee
is subject to a certain trendiness
is vulnerable to fashioned what's hot
now what's cool now and that global
warming was very cool no joke intended
in 2007 and the 2008 Awards a little bit
more traditional it was given to a
Finnish troubleshooter un diplomat named
Otto sorry but some people have said
that the committee should be where
celebrity Awards celebrity selections
there been a number of celebrities in
Oslo in recent years but Obama being
maybe the maybe the biggest now but the
committee likes to say there are many
paths to peace and so it's given to
diplomats and given to humanitarians
mother Teresa microlenders global
warming campaigners
Aurra thought different paths to peace
and they almost always have a case I
think the global warming award was
reading my own view of core and the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change III think that award is probably
a little far afield for the Nobel Peace
Prize a set your departure from the will
that I'm not sure it was defensible but
it's their award the five Norwegians on
the committee determined the award and
the rest of us are just spectators who
pick at it when did you learn about the
Obama prize and the course in doing the
book when what did you learn yeah did
you did you I'll tell you something
that's not in the book this directly I
think it's a little oblique in the book
right after bomb was announced someone
in Norway very familiar with all this
said to me know why the game the prize
let's remember now that Barack Obama's
now in a dogfight maybe that's not the
right word given recent events before
the presidency but and in in 2009 he was
at rock star heights you know the great
messianic figure around the globe and so
this guy tells me after the award was
announced you know why they gave me word
they just wanted him to come to Oslo
they have this bobble to give and he's
the the world's great rock star at the
biggest celebrity the number-one figure
how do we bring the US President
President Obama to our to our remote icy
little capital well we got the Nobel
Peace Prize to to give him and you know
the committee he's wanted to bask in his
glory and then well the committee
chairman if I could get a boost him in
Europe to have Obama's the winner so
Matt I hear this this one fellow say
this and I think to my I'm very proud
think of myself what's ridiculous that's
just nonsense
I heard from a second Norwegian and a
ninth then a 15 then a 25th I'm in
Norway and I discover that whether it's
true or not
everyone thinks everyone thinks it I I
don't know
did I III think that Obama is a person
after the Norwegian Nobel Committee his
own heart I think he they view him as
sharing a world of you they consider him
a kind of political or philosophical
soulmate a fellow social democrat i
think george w bush was a president out
of their nightmares and barack obama's a
president out of their fondest dreams i
think i say in the book that if the
nobel committee could design an american
president from scratch he would turn out
a lot like barack obama so it was a bit
of a natural and it was a way of saying
in a way but from their point of view is
a way of saying dingdong the witch is
dead that rotten george w bush is no
longer in the oval office
there's this wonderful new guy we are
blessing a new day and yet he comes
across in the as you recount the episode
as maybe a little embarrassed about the
whole thing he seems so to me
didn't he yeah it seemed a little
sheepish but he first came out at a
white house there too he said something
like well this has been an interesting
morning yeah he handled it very
graciously obama did i think he was put
in a really awkward spot i always
presume part of it was it was a
politically awkward position for him to
be yeah yeah and then throughout his
visit to oslo i think an accepting of
the prize i think he was he tried hard
to be modest and actually in his speech
he harkens back a bit more perhaps than
people were expecting to some of that
peace through strength theme yes yes he
did that but that's exactly right he did
give the iraq war the back of his hand
he didn't even use the word iraq he said
something like one is a war that's
winding down and then he defended the
afghan war quite strongly and he also
said that the piece of security of
Europe
have been
I have been supported by the blood of
the American soldier things like that
George Marshall Ike things it was one of
us more I would say hawkish addresses
that's true we're coming close to the
end so I want to ask you in the biggest
sense is the Peace Prize a good idea did
you come away from the book thinking the
Peace Prize make sense adds to the world
for all of its flaws or that if it went
away tomorrow wouldn't matter well you
put your finger on an important question
and it's one I forced myself to answer
in the afterword of my book I figured I
owed it to readers to say whether I
thought the Peace Prize was worthwhile
and by the way I hope there's enough
information in this book to allow
readers to make up their own minds about
the Nobel Peace Prize I give my opinion
now and then mean more than now and then
but also I hope enough facts so that
people can make up their own minds
I you may remember this story I was M I
was in the vigeland sculpture park in
Oslo and I was buying a book from a
vendor and because I had kind of my
reporters hat on I asked him what do you
think of the Nobel Peace Prize any first
answered as a Norwegian or a Norwegian
citizen and he said well it put Norway
on the map then he said I often don't
agree with decisions of the committee
but I think it's probably good to have
one prize for peace amid so many other
prizes for so many other things and I
agree genuine peace is a wonderful thing
and if someone can affect fraternity
between nations and that someone
deserves a prize even one worth 1.5
million dollars which the Nobel Prizes
are worth today it's just this question
of what is peace and who deserves what
is peace and who deserves to be crowned
a champion of peace and not just a
champion of peace but the world's
foremost we all have our own opinions
and someone's got to decide and you and
I'm I think we could do better but it's
in as the British say it's in the gift
of these five Norwegians I think you're
very generous about the process because
it seems clear even when you disagree at
I'm strongly with with a choice you seem
to respect the process and the fact that
that discussion is going on every year
even if sometimes it goes off the rails
yes and I think on balance it's
worthwhile unbalanced gun to my head of
her up to me to continue it or ditch it
let me regret this later
I would continue it there's a parlor
game always associated with the Peace
Prize of course and we haven't gotten to
talk as much parlor game as I would have
liked but I just want to finish by
asking when you look out there with what
you learned of the prize in the world
today who might be out there who's a
future of Peace Prize winner or should
be whether they are going to be or not
well I refer to the Clinton Global
Initiative as Nobel baked but he may
have to wait a while because they've
given it to American presidents and
former presidents and vice presidents
recently so there have to be a decent
interval well they also probably don't
need to give him a prize to get him to
come to Oz lawyer man yeah that's right
that's right
III think it'd be a wonderful thing if
we're given to some Cuban figure some
democracy activist freedom activist a
prisoner of conscience someone like
Oscar Bessette I doubt I think it'll be
a cold day you know where when the
Norwegian Nobel Committee gives the
Nobel Peace Prize to a Cuban freedom
figure the the great Cuban dissident
Armando Valladares the author of against
all hope sometimes call the Cuban
Solzhenitsyn remarked me with some
justifiable bitterness I think if the
Cuban dictatorship were right-wing
instead of left-wing we'd have one two
or three Nobel Prizes already I think
that's true I think that's true Ashley
and I think the Nobel Peace Prize to a
Cuban freedom figure would rock that
dictatorship little island dictatorships
been there since the late 1950s the
Nobel Peace Prize would be a very big
deal there they could give white they
give it to groups and institutions now
and then these women who put their and
stick their necks out by holding
candlelight vigils and so on and
and publicly praying for their loved
ones in prison I it would be an awfully
good thing I think of a Norwegian
Committee gave the prize to a Cuban but
um I wouldn't wait up nights well we're
out of time that was a pretty negative
note to end on well you if you do want
to throw it any other last minute
positive father you know III think not
you and I think not
maybe maybe end on a touch of gloom but
what a bright day would be if the
Norwegian Committee followed through on
that they gave it to a Chinese freedom
figure in 22 2010 right after 60 years
of passing them over they bit the bullet
in 2010 I gave to you Chavo who sits in
a Cell today and I hope it's doing him
in this movement some good generally oh
thank you very much for the great
discussion the book is peace they say
it's been a pleasure likewise thank you
man